[Laughter]
grinning some podcast Vil it's Monday
April what 13th yeah April 13th it's a
beautiful [ __ ] day to be alive
for starters the church is brought to
you by stamps calm everyone is avoiding
crowds right now you me everybody but if
you need to go to the post office what
are you gonna do you might be running a
small business trying to ship a product
or send invoices but anything you do at
the post office
you can do with stamps calm I got big
news for you people
stamps calm is now working with UPS get
more delivery options and all the great
discounts on postage that you used to be
able to with stamps calm and UPS my wife
[ __ ] send sweatshirts the whole thing
if it wasn't for stamps calm
she'd be done why stand on a [ __ ]
line what are you another commie knock
it off right now they got a special
offer for the church family you ready
grab a pen you're gonna get a four week
trial plus a free pre postage and a
digital scale no long term commitments
no contracts it's easy go to stamps calm
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and press in church do me
that favor CH you are CH that stance
calm press in church stay safe my
friends take this [ __ ] meal
Oh
[Music]
Easter stop stickers
but today's Monday you bad [ __ ]
a beautiful day to be alive I got my
beautiful cousin sister my Goomba
[ __ ] I don't know to come in yeah a
couple of minutes we don't have to do no
[ __ ] zoom boom in my life if I was
gonna risk anything for anybody it'd be
you Joe Diaz what the [ __ ] you've been
in quarantine you've been well I've been
in quarantine I've been hiding out it
locked me in by yourself right yeah all
by myself it's exciting when was the
last time he did stand-up I did in my
mirror a couple days ago I was bombed
hard you know when all this started
remember all of us like ah there's
nothing we're gonna all go to [ __ ]
ends up live and do comedy and one night
you get up in here like you didn't try
it no no I was java did great on his
shoulder first week during first week it
was so bad and I'm like a JAMA I love
the bomb I'm gonna die Aslaug done yeah
so I'm gonna try this [ __ ] do it [ __ ]
I'm not doing it people keep texting me
or not texting but hit me up on like the
social media platforms they're like well
you do stand-up in your living room on
my Grich I don't have a living room I
live in a studio you want me to stand by
my bed I don't wanna do nothing and my
couch no I do not I don't want to know
nothing sick nobody's party I don't do
not know I don't mind podcast that I'm a
got enough problem doing my own podcast
in home school [ __ ] school
well I'm like Joe Diaz did your teacher
you might and I gotta go in there make
sure everything is all right honky
doodle you know I showed how to play
dice I do the whole talking oh you're
good yeah no I do the matter I try to
make them mad different there's a
different approach to Method Man [ __ ]
idiots the math they teach you yeah oh
how many times have you used calculus
and if you graduated high school you had
calculus what about that [ __ ] thing
that you put the needle in and spin it
around
we don't need that I use it all you need
to know how to count gay this and count
give this on a move give me [ __ ] five
times on the Jets
five times in the Nixon a five time
parlay you gotta have that figured out
all and you [ __ ] copy ahead bad files
to win six dollars to lose [ __ ] yeah I
can parlay what is it 35 to lose 70 to
win that's it that's all you know you
got to work like that man works quickly
so I'm trying to get her to do the math
and that's it just wait not the storm
I'm not as depressed as most people oh I
go up and down I go up and down I have
my nights I have like three good nights
and then one night I sit down I go what
are they doing communist Cuba they
probably have better music well you can
go out you go to a park you know this is
I understand the ramifications of this a
lot and I get it I get all this [ __ ] so
are you still going out and going to
parks they closed most of them right
like you can't yeah it doesn't take a
genius the first time I went walking I
walked like for two days and then I
realized that I got [ __ ] behind
me and I got people in front of me yeah
you like and you're sucking in their
exhaust it doesn't take a genius to know
that and when there's 40 people there I
work off percentages percentages is what
I work off yeah the more people the
higher potential you have if you go
[ __ ] again what do they say six feet
yeah I'm usually a 12 foot type of
[ __ ] and it's really 27 because
if I sneeze that's how long it's they
clear that's how you clear a room oh
here we go
my eyes are gonna that's got [ __ ]
whatever it so it kills everything just
sanitizer okay yeah that's me I need
that for the grocery so we've got the
Lysol see if you got these these are
tremendous what is a mace mace mace for
[ __ ] social distancing me a social
distancing people come over
no I died right your I've long that's it
you tweeted something or put something
up about people coming over to talk to
your dog and [ __ ] no people come over
and they bring that stupid ugly dog and
they talk they're interesting like that
you want to hear about this stupid dog
exactly and I get we have you know
you're not supposed to pet a dog right
now you're not supposed to do she's a
human being
yeah okay I'm not mad at anybody nobody
should take this wrong I understand the
needs yeah from the psychological the
needs of the human being we need contact
when he touch we need love we need water
we need a lot of things yeah okay so
when you're at a park when you read a
supermarket you know I'm not worried
about at all
I'm not worried about me the worried
about the other people yeah the guy I'm
either hasn't taken a shower you know he
does have a [ __ ] coffee and he is
coughing into his hand he's touching
[ __ ] he's looking at calories in the
sodium cuz those are the jerk offs that
do that yeah yeah all those people the
jokes that do that Susan next door to me
told me third for Dallas she went to 65
and over shopping she goes she never saw
anything like that I like at Gelson's if
you go at 6:00 in the morning yeah it's
for people over 64 right she said at
6:00 in the morning she saw a lady
tasting a soup she had a mask on she
pulled up a mask is soup and put it back
into the soup and closed it like a salad
dip that was on that's why that you know
that's gonna disappear from the world
all that stuff all that stuff that's all
gone discuss in the new world this is
all moving on that's it you're not gonna
go to men cheese no more that's what I'm
Matt I love men cheese you think of New
York
and your girls as the things on the
outside but as human needs if they put
both of us on island
don't talk to them we had a war with
them 2,000 years ago whatever but we
have to walk outside the compound meat
will go on to prison I learn that I
learned that even people who were
enemies once there's a circle when
people start walking you get closer to
each other it's what what we do yeah it
won't just start migrating toward it
hasn't set in two people I was already
all in it March 2nd why I stopped going
to the storm March 2nd I don't know that
that was through the last time I went
into the store because I could still see
the hogs and people let me take a
picture oh my did you not see the same
news I saw today yeah so right down
there last time I went I was March 7th
and after this and you know then you see
what it attacks it attacks this this
this this and this so I'm high [ __ ]
rest so it's over yeah so you're smarter
see you later bye
I was out there till they said you can't
go out no more 14 yeah yeah the 14th and
then I did the Laugh Factory was the
only place open the store closed because
they were doing this is itching my nose
they were doing just the original room
which is smaller obviously and you know
because you can only have certain amount
of people out and then Peter who owns
the store he he was like nope this is
bad
we're gonna we don't want the liability
which is kind of smart yeah I know for a
fact of his mother was still running it
she would still be fighting everyone to
keep it open right now
that's just how she was and but he was
smart to do that because they are making
money and legally if somebody gets sick
there they could get Sukup a bit but the
Laugh Factory the there just that one
room and he was stayed open
he stayed open till I think I did three
extra shows for Jaime he's doing right
now a live streaming comedy yeah during
the day so I did it one day it it felt
good as a
like to get that out but like he they
clean everything there's no more it's
the same as this except for we were
further apart and it was me Alonzo
Bodden and build Oz and it I felt good
you could see people writing in like you
know what asking questions but I
couldn't read it it was too small so I
was just like I'm just gonna keep
telling what my quarantine is like and I
wound up doing like 35 minutes but I got
it out Jay and I like that Jamie's doing
it Tiffany Haddish did it the other day
like it's just it's different than
standing in your living room and like
you know holding a microphone and being
like you're at a comedy club you're on a
stage and it just you're just telling
what your [ __ ] is like basically it's
keeping the Laugh Factory alive I guess
they're small they're not gonna you're
gonna be a tough survival I'm not ready
for that yet I'm not ready
psychologically I'm not ready at all I'm
ready to get up on a stage
I really missed a mister stage and like
I've been I don't watch new [ __ ] my
whole world is still Hicks and more
lines I love that brother I've watched a
bunch of old def Comedy Jam I found the
one that I was looking for with DL
Hughley hosting and getting a standing
ovation okay that's the one that's a
little later oh oh yeah I watched that
one then I [ __ ] my head boo up
because I want to go out I wanted to go
out yeah that's a problem with watching
you're a kid yeah as a kid I would watch
a basketball game from one to four and
you wanted to learn the moves and I was
a little quarter four and do the moves
that they did so here hey you are that's
what I used to do watch those old tapes
yeah I watched an old special from HBO
the other night that wasn't the best in
the world you know looking at it now
Hicks was wild he's a prolific he was ya
know know
it wasn't necessarily like you're right
he didn't Rock'em Sock'em yeah he wanted
to get someone getting out of a certain
way I watched he was really saying
something
oh I always watched Andrew from Philly
oh that's what made him famous what made
them fast I watched that again I've been
watching
I was Joan Rivers a lot I wanted to
watch the stuff that made me fall in
love with Tommy oh yeah falling in love
with Tommy
gradual again that little romance well
yeah we're on the phone we're not
[ __ ] yet like 20 hours old
your mom's yelling it yeah my bets what
I'm going through right now I'm going
through that romance you know it's a
different romance I know I got another
it'll be another two they say May 15
I say so first talking about another six
weeks before we could really even if
they do four I'm still gonna give it a
week or two that night you got you got
something to live good I want to let
people go out first okay and do that
thing you know and really let them and
then see how the store pans are who
comes back yeah who didn't move to
Chicago
yeah I'm a clean person man this is for
crumbs the crumbs gotta go you gotta
remember that this is this devastating
nationwide as an earthquake of course
people gonna rethink look at what we're
doing we're doing a podcast with masks
on you know weird this is people gonna
rethink their lives they're gonna
rethink is this one is it worth going
out yeah I asked a friend of mine about
another friend of mine from me that was
having a hard time and I asked him he
goes he's gone he went back oh yeah
thank God cuz he wouldn't the last at
these two months here this is two months
of hell yeah
a lot of people yeah I know a lot of
people that left a lot of people in town
a lot of people picked up and said we'll
come back on the party results yeah
if the party resumes party's gonna
resume yeah but it's
resume a different way yeah that we've
ever and nobody knows how so don't worry
nice enjoy this time off I know a lot of
people are struggling right now
financially I told you I'm on the phone
for three weeks ago not the way for a
jack yeah I told you three weeks ago not
the way for a check to get a mask go all
the routes Pathmark shop right shock and
fresh Gordo's bakery all those places a
Pathmark yeah all those places need all
those places we need help right now at
night yeah my brother Johnny's doing it
as a bartender and he's doing it in
Philadelphia I told the friend the money
was only playing a lot 11 an hour long
the government's gonna give you this let
me get that check you're absolutely
right go to work I'm telling you I'm
guessing from explain a little where I'm
gonna work I might do it myself don't
wait for [ __ ] this I don't feel I
don't suck I know atomic right now a
dear friend comic that has a night job
and that's one of the other yes I I'm
not gonna do this I'm not because I
can't sit there at night thinking about
this [ __ ] go crazy I got myself a little
night job he goes I'm not gonna make a
lot of money but I'm doing it Jesse goes
I keep your mind busy the only thing I
won't do is uber like I'll do no eat
I don't mind dropping [ __ ] off to you
but I can't do pick up people well I
didn't even getting in an uber now I
wouldn't get in an uber now I don't know
those are the ones dying first
and that's something for look at others
all younger kids who listen to this and
we've talked about how like all it is
weird and stuff but it's also like you
have to pick you have to pick your
careers differently I think a lot career
change well like yeah my brother's a
bartender yeah we work with live
performance so you we need audience we
need customers if you will if I was a
kid I might be looking you know I may be
able to get into apps I can do that from
home what building apps or just just
anything you can do from home now do
that build an ad or we can't do what I'm
saying the kids going to college kid
gets too late for us
I thought you met Osso though build an
app I can't even do a zoom podcast I'm
an idiot
it's
look it's not a check we don't know what
it's going to do I have no you know my
dates were scattered anyway I didn't
really have a sum add a lot right now I
was gonna surprise a movie or yeah push
back photos but it doesn't take a genius
how they gonna do it are you gonna set
foot on a movie September 25th
everything's backed up already
unless you nothing's really been
released the last three weeks right and
released rolled and I watched rolls yeah
night wouldn't they put Ozark out a
little earlier yeah I'm talking about
movies movies I was supposed to come out
the next couple weeks they're not coming
out I think I didn't AMC close the time
about it yeah yeah why can't they do it
like streaming like on TV that's trying
to figure out now I mean all these
things they cannot know everybody
sitting there it's like a hotel with
teen leaders now where did it go
ready to go back ready to go I saw
something that was very smart the place
on Suns on Ventura Boulevard they switch
their restaurant around quickly so you
get sushi at the window Oh like the [ __ ]
yeah a lot of people are doing that
thing
so that's smart right now if you're a
restaurant owner you really want to make
money switch to a window but a glass on
it were a little hold just like they do
in New York
yep click we can stick their hand in
boom boom to not only thing that goes it
is to your pad for your ding there's
outside there's a wiper waiting for your
gloves to wipe the pan after you do it
and start selling [ __ ] burritos and
tacos that'll go for quick but what will
happen is you get the congregation of
people that wait in their line yeah I've
seen a line get the [ __ ] out you know
get the [ __ ] out
yeah that's the problem you have that
today supposedly all the parks are
closed
yeah like today except that was a gaggle
of idealist yeah I think they were
homeless I got to be honest cuz it they
were just like all together and I was
like are they having a meeting like
where should we go or where is everybody
because I live right behind a really
busy
and a beauty supply and I am Telling You
la is such a strange city to go through
something like this with every day
including today a woman pulled up in a
Porsche went right up to the restaurant
pulling the door like really one it's
Easter ho - we're in a pandemic you
think these people are open this is the
best restaurant in Los Angeles or
whatever like a very what are you doing
hey that's your mask this is great this
thing everybody I'm excited remember we
live in a look
Ellie's a strange place right still
pulling up to the beauty supply store
gone
are you serious I'm like yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] idiot Java all of the last week
I adore him for doing I mean he killed
the Italian parliament when they started
yelling at people all the mayors what
they were saying their people was not
yeah yeah it was great scumbags and
we're not talking tell your public the
way ours
no that's what we need we need real [ __ ]
this dude was like why hear about them
people coming over to mobile people yeah
one guy one island just rammed exercises
he just distorted them stay always
buster yeah gained a good ten pounds you
know I find a lot of waiting I didn't
get as much as I did I gained like two
pounds I don't have a scale you have a
scale of a scale that was scary I don't
have one I'm not your average chick I
got what I was scared I was like that's
not bad but I haven't gone crazy either
I have I am NOT going great how do you
cope with the last three so you've been
home three weeks well dude I've been
home since March 14 March 15th
no States no stage time yeah that's
making me a little nutty so you've been
home st. Patty's Day yeah
so you thinking like I'll just okay I'll
bake I like to pay I was gonna go back
to Philly and then I was worried because
I was supposed to be in Philly that week
with dice I had a bunch of dates and
they all got canceled Portland Reno we
were in Philadelphia Chicago Michigan
all got canceled
so which is fine whatever I get it we
got to figure this out but I was like
what am I gonna do if I go to Philly
my mom's 82 I don't want to be another
person I had into god forbid cuz that I
gotta fly there so then I gotta go in
quarantine for another 14 days I can't
be near her anyway
you know what I mean so I was just like
I'm just gonna stay here I'm I'll bake
I'll keep myself busy I'll do podcasts I
started I started playing with my
youtube channel I'm like I'll do rants
what a dick and so now then I started
baking and I made like a 7-up cake and
cheesecake cupcakes Cinnamon cupcakes
all kinds of [ __ ] but I'm just eating
them like okay and then I'm like why do
I feel so sick and now I feel like a
beached whale just stuck in the
apartment well your emotions feel a
little crazy like some days I'm just
start crying for no reason I'm like is
this menopause or they're pandemic like
you have to figure it's hard to figure
out which is which so I cuz I'm close
I'm on I think this is menopause age I
don't know but you know I'd like you're
when you start getting emotional like
that I get a little freaked out I'm like
what do I do I said I was like alright
I'll finish my script I have no focus
focus
I need I need to be smart adderall how
crazy is that
you sit down you go to write I've
written I haven't written a bit but I
have written funny snippets same can I
have our cell over my apartment caught
myself saying funny
stoned snip ha ha ha make me and Lea
giggle yeah yeah have written them down
as something starting process but as far
as writing I did write something I was
impressed with like I know I was high
when I was right there
and how do you write do you type into
your hand right I go from a notebook
first get a couple sentences going a
notebook and I concrete it type it out
in the computer and I never do the
second part and I since I have two hours
you always working on mm-hmm
you add word needs to be on the show but
I've been known for the last two years
the iPad has been a game changer for me
it has helped me more than I don't have
know writing if you ask me is it an app
no it's just called whatever no just got
a feather on it yeah want me to sit
there and I came up with the next what
the narrative should be for my next
special oh okay that's good that's a big
deal if I'm looking at a time frame I'm
really looking at 2021 to start doing
family again I got a week in June and
Brea which might work might not work
well that's right here yeah open and
about 40 people to show yeah
hopefully this is the good thing about
this is something I was thinking about
the other day is that for me right now
it's my turn to shine if when comedy
comes back cuz most people like you sell
out theaters and stuff so you're not
gonna want to perform in front of 20
people I've been doing that for years
I'm fine with it alone they could sit
six foot six feet apart remember one
thing that I am very excited about a lot
of things right now I am more excited
than depressed I am more excited about
the future I've already mourned the past
yeah I've mourned that I understand that
forty percent of my audience has
evaporated do
financial financial health all of it
yancha problems this is just the way it
is
mmm if you were selling 3,000 tickets a
monkey and now selling 1,600 yeah no
question it's not that you didn't get
funny it's that you charge money and
there's no Iraq right now people just
don't have it so you have to assume all
these things upfront my ticket prices
are going right back to 25 yeah you know
Thursday night 20 I'm here with you and
this battle with you yeah I'm right I'll
play the numbers if it's 200 a weekend
it's two what a weekend until I get a
vaccine see myself going five hours on a
plane the plane is the hardest part I
think yeah for us I could tell you right
now this is why I'm maxing you by your
anxiety levels at your house during the
daytime have you tried to exercise oh I
do so many exercise that's the that's
why I'm not a thousand pounds overweight
but I I'll just put you tube on I'll do
a class with somebody my friend stayshia
does a class every day at noon Rocco's
doing yoga
Rocco still at noon you know Ari Shaffir
is doing yoga if you want like if you
want it for funny or not or whatever
everybody's trying to help each other
and it's all free so you can do classes
with people like when I did my friend
Stacy Asst she's built amazing and so
she had like 30 people on there and we
were just killing it doing all kinds of
exercise and you feel way better if you
exercise but then there's days when I
get up and I'm like I'm up I'm not doing
it today I'm not exercising I'm just
gonna lay here like a lump you know I'm
that it gets it'll take over I've been
doing something six days a week just so
I stay active
I'm not doing my complete workout yeah
I'm doing some kettlebells kettlebells I
hate to hold the Mitzvah mercy and make
myself walk around
I had a bounce challenge I have a nine
pound ball on a 16-pound ball and we
tried to slam him you know and key this
into the workout the first oh thank you
who doesn't know that workouts she's
like daddy that's the same thing we did
I go yeah but you know jump to it so
it's even better out there yes I think
the exercise has helped me exercise
truly it's always helped me but now it's
helping me if I'm wrong so weird how
much just really put the stress on you
and you guys at home know what I'm
talking about because what I for me to
warm up I just draw I just hit the
pocket boxing okay I want you back do
you have a bag at your house I would
kill for that bag that bag be broken
right now if I had people on the streets
life in doing stupid [ __ ]
let's go would know oh yeah I chased a
guy out of my carport the other night
the windows yeah it's weird so I hid the
bag as a warm-up and I know two minutes
it is different cuz this breathing and
the stress is so high so I got to really
push the five minutes I put a timer on
my iPhone but I really push it to five
minutes and then after I do the first
five minutes that's okay and then I do
another five and then I'm little better
and then I get them sixteen Pombo and
slam it yeah third five now I'm really
good I'm like okay now I see why I'm
doing this I like that sweat to come out
of me and yeah those white drugs Oh
oh my god the smell that comes out of me
THC my wife goes when I smell it I open
up she gets high the dryer with your
sweatshirt in it it smells like
buermeyer wallet oh my god it's like in
there for good it's in my system I'm
lucky to be able to sweat and do all
that [ __ ] in the backyard
yeah the yard is big yeah I'm doing it
in front of my TV in the right the
studio which is kind of annoying I mean
I could
go I lit like the alley is empty so I
could go out there and jump rope and
stuff pretty much but then you got to
deal with the vagrants the vagrants just
walk by or they're paying the ants it a
couple of them have set up you know the
tents and stuff which could just be
people from my building the can't afford
rent that moved who knows you know what
it means I don't I don't mess with them
unless they do stupid [ __ ]
then I yell I'm like a Mack get out like
I'll just scare them and then they
usually if as soon as they hear
something they run away you know they're
like here comes a crazy lady why is she
carrying a baseball bat that's
uncomfortable I got like a 45 pound
kettlebell 335 I have a 15 and then I
got two 15s both of them it different
okay you got a lot of kettlebells I only
have one farmer walks well you hold
farmer carries all firemen carry you
just walk with it yeah I do five minutes
and I'm [ __ ] gone the next day I do
that with jugs of water you gotta listen
if you don't do that the stress will
build definitely I have to move around a
lot right now I know on my limite like I
already in my mind I have a timetable
it's so weird that they did a poll and
they said that 70% of people will not go
to an event without a vaccination right
now yeah thinking wow if that poll even
they say most polls at 10% off oh yeah
all wish was shot yeah that's what I'm
telling you we lost 40% of our audience
yeah so what you're trying to tell me is
we're going to open and the first three
months we're gonna be limited schedule
to September yeah I made my run 500
people and then we'll start back up on
that I'd say not see the NFL on that
time today but I know my nephew got
called back to baseball in May okay yeah
they're gonna go back because but
they're going back with no hot dog read
this yeah and no popcorn I hate hot dog
they'll take a chunk this year but next
year if they can't do this again they're
coming back with a Dodger package you
mind before for the whole season
what do you know you're red
Oxfam well we'll give you the Red Sox
and the Dodgers yeah yeah 384 all the
games just their games no more watching
what are you guys thinking about because
I'm new so I feel like I'm basically
starting over
oh you guys are talking about like
getting audience to the show but like
how are you guys gonna be I'd stand up
with an effort to month break I'm
starting all over
Sam I think we're all starting slate
yeah yeah yeah I'm not taking a week no
where nobody wants to see me and I'm not
watch them nobody's if I haven't been on
stage for two months right you're gonna
meet again i am socially cleansed
yeah i am starting from scratch there is
nothing to come watch why do you think i
told these people two months ago to take
your money back I told them already
taking money back people feel so good
myself
they give me a pill because I'm holding
out for the pill do you think you're
gonna shoot me how long you think before
vaccine I don't have a [ __ ] fortune
teller I will tell you what's gonna
happen for Joey they're gonna open up
the city they're gonna open up one of
these comedy clubs I'm gonna call him
for three spots the two spots a week the
first two weeks
I'm calling get my immune system up to
talk to people okay just to test people
maybe you want to take a picture don't
even elbow me yeah cuz I'm like this
sweatshirt on fire I'm ordering a bunch
of disposable flammable shirts that just
go on flames minutes okay I already got
a plan I'm taking my shirts are like
your bass I'm buying them jeans new
everything and I'm taking covered
clothes
Kolbe closet come in I gotta go into the
garage and take my Colburn outfit off
and I got my own personal bathroom
shower in the back behind the office
[ __ ] the best shower and now house
nobody use the best you can lay down
whack off I can lay down on my back like
a [ __ ] I'm like I'm doing the last pose
in yoga
namaste what's that I don't I don't do
your bars and I believe you [ __ ]
[ __ ] think of all the bad things in
your life I could somebody could sleep
in my [ __ ] shower that's oh my god
that's one rate and the last night I
went to the comedy store I turn that
shower on I heart the only problem it's
got it doesn't flood as quick as the
water comes in so you gotta be careful
on that oh is it clogs or you just it
just does my brain woke up next thing
you know so yeah I did everything you
could take like an eight-minute shower
on there but you can't bang one out
which is the whole thing is that water
moving and you're banging that little
safe in the stomach to come you like I
usually goes right over the drain the
high arc the other day I saw some poor
bastard over here by the fire this was a
whole can off No ah they were watching
the fire trucks and a homeless guy a
black dude just like Clint Eastwood I
just make the right on [ __ ] I just
make the left on Magnolia okay either
towards the fire department I'm doing
the speed limit I'm in no rush there's
nobody on the streets
I think I'm doing like 15 I'm just
chillin coasting yeah I'm driving like
I'm in prison I'm back you say your
ankle braces yeah I see this homeless
dude coming out from like the corner
he's like man it's a beautiful land to
be alive and also he saw the fire
charred getting washing those water oh
no you made
I hate you on the floor on the corner
and he would dig his head into the
stream that was coming from her fire
department and he was just drinking like
a water drinks like a cat drinks water
yeah just like that I pulled up next to
him and I was like the world has come to
an end and I just kept driving and then
thank God I saw my homeless dude the
gorilla yeah six foot six 280 the black
dude I just give him 20 bucks every time
I see him I just put on the collar they
give me one of these nice that Matt I
see him by my house patrolling the area
because he knows where I was sure you
want that 20 bro every time I see him I
do come in 20 everybody else is
desperate they're not desperate they've
always been in the desperate the
homeless so they're you know where we
feel crazy
but they're not they've always been this
I've been trying to help them more than
yeah be to Allah copper I didn't eat
them cupcake from the house I'm so much
value no wonder they're bye-bye
Riverside I'm gonna bridge ah there's a
Starbucks coffee it's Riverside meat to
hunger longer I dropped them some books
the other day and they were very
thankful yeah and I won't do if I'm
thrown out the window I pulled all but
it was a red light sure and I brought
the bottom I go here you go guys is some
boxes again some more coke outside I had
and I had some hamburger buns again man
yeah water for granted took all those
black t-shirts that people sent me all
my fat man sweat clothes all and brought
it up to the they opened up a shelter I
saw it on the news so I think Tuesday my
wife dropped it off let me know cuz I
got things of whatever I put a couple
things of spaghetti sauce in there okay
you know whatever cuz I said I had extra
stuff in the house yeah that I could
pass up it's not it's ragu I'm always
ready for an earthquake I want to help
but I don't have money money you don't
have little things yeah you have little
things like oh allah video
so I tell people are on errands you know
I took a bunch of I went to the to the
best piece of place and whatever what's
the place I gonna um Pizza wagon the
people are gonna Brooklyn I want to get
that today oh my god is it open
it's open call my mom Oliver Sicilian
Steve Simone told me about that pull up
in front of the place I want to go as
Eleanor's already yes there's nobody in
there the doors are wide open you don't
have to I don't get on venture right I'm
bent or I'm gone I don't go nowhere
where the door is open I'm still if
you're gonna open up a door you already
that your percentages just wanted to get
culprit it's gonna be a dwarf fresco
what do they call you a little
restaurant fresco I'm looking for a
table do you want inside a fresco what
are you talking about no I'm with you
aqua fresca
you got what you leave here right now
I'm calling them and you Tom I'll be
there
Joey uncle Joey sent me and Steve Simone
hey he's been telling me for months you
go up there the pizza we're gonna do a
podcast there but yeah thing hit he
loves it you give him a tip to the guy
whatever he wants yes to that brother
how much I know water bottles so I had
my wife bring them water bottles when I
was up that brought them water bottles
as my wife bring the water bottles to
the shelter
okay I was going over that she was going
for the woman's place and the homeless
we just cleaned out everything I guess
t-shirts are everywhere man yeah well I
just had to send them out I sent out a
few juju - jeez okay so homeless
[ __ ] wants a turn to do if you
saw a homeless guy walking around you
just I would pull over take a picture
give me 20 you should get your homeless
guy oh gee that's a big guy no I don't
want to know nothing yeah yeah that's
got a weapon on him oh I'll have a smell
yeah I know it smells like not
everybody's your
he's got to do how much have you been
calling your friends that are on house
arrest like hey man now I understand how
anybody else arrests but I knew it I
don't have any friends on house arrest
oh I've been I've been to prison so you
I have one morning off four years you
understand the four walls yeah you've
been in prison I tell people all the
time but does that's [ __ ] with your
anxiety from that mm-hmm I've been very
good because I'd learned how to move
from room to room okay
I learned how to this all these things
you could do
yeah save yourself a lot of time you
broke you you just heard let me explain
something to you three weeks ago two
weeks goes on the Rogan podcast as we
know Rogan works for the EEOC and has
multiple jobs Chuck Rogan is well off I
asked him if he had been writing comedy
and he said no it's um focus either
nobody's focusing guys so if you're
having a hard time there don't get in a
line don't stress on everybody's having
a hard time focusing be yeah I don't
have a hard time with that's really been
helping me reading that Ababwa Lingus
that's great it takes a few pages okay
you gotta force yourself to go free pick
those three pages you read you'll have
to come back to them and read them yeah
that's what I've been doing but I've
read I finished the book and I read
another book I got a page rookie got me
there's a Jimmy Page book that's gonna
hold me over for the rest of this you
know it's a great one wired every wired
by the SNL book yes that's a great one
that's visit listen this thousand great
books that you talked about and there's
a million that you don't yeah so I have
the alchemist I have all kinds of yeah I
heard I have a lot of books that are old
I've read like I really wanted to read
like you know what I want to go through
too right now what I was telling my wife
last night my wife and I was sitting at
my wife came to her because I want
anything I go out with
like this sweatshirt is freshly our
laundry
okay but since I had contact with you
only and I'm probably gonna go for a
ride after this I went to the weed store
this morning I wash this again sure
these are the outside clothes saying
tomorrow this all goes in the last thing
I got home I went outside to smoke a
number I hadn't smoked all bad and
smoked in like three days
I was really good on the reef I've been
doing one bong hit show like that but no
and yes I was I have to really go for
smoking enjoy that wasn't I supposed to
join I came in and I want to get on the
floor and stretch so my wife came into
hanging the stuff oh he's gonna pop out
of me and she asked me you okay I'm okay
I asked her how she is doing what I
could tell my wife was having a
frustrating day yesterday his mercy he's
getting frustrated yeah and it kind of
hurts your feelings because you can't
fix it can't fix it so I told it all
you're not seven yeah you can't
understand the language what the
language yeah and then my friend started
call on the back in the house everybody
calm and I told my wife something that
was really weird that just started
coming out and it was the truth I think
I gotta be honest with you the last four
years but it wasn't a level where I
wasn't to be gone nothing I want to be
Katt Williams I'm not talking about that
I love that you pick you know I love to
watch that tremendous what you don't
like no I love it
okay I was like tremendous yeah that's
great
Katt Williams like whenever one could
see so big I wanna be Katt Williams a
cabin are and I'm happy Who I am
yeah but you know what I missed I missed
that having listened when somebody pays
25 bucks 30 bucks 30 to 50
come see me I know they went to a
restaurant I like boy weed yeah yeah for
a guy like me there's a little bit of
pressure but there's not but I got a
reality there is a little bit of
pressure yeah
it means I'm gonna take this money
Gamble's as I would be gambling I want
you to go home and tell your friends you
have a really good [ __ ] time all
right when I go to the store Tuesday
night I'm that Joe Diaz yeah I don't
care if you get up and walk the [ __ ] out
the store stores the story got knowing I
really don't care if you get out and
walk out and write a letter
oh I love it when you write a letter I
love when you what I used to go in there
jelly but Paul Mooney we literally had a
big file cabinet filler god oh my god I
would watch them get up and run out
that's a podcast wipe to white tourists
yeah what's the area next door and he'd
go up there and [ __ ] scare them too
they run out oh go ahead Hobie run off
so right now what I want to do is I want
that I want this to get back yeah I want
people to recover financially I'm not
looking for you to go anywhere I'm
saying for what I wanna do my plan
because remember man without a plan
there's not a man I know you're broke I
know you have a hard time but at the
same time you should be what are your
plans gonna be with or without money
what are you gonna do you're not gonna
have the money you are that's more
business loan they've changed that four
times in one week
oh my god yeah so don't worry about
nothing nobody's get none remember
remember that expression the best lining
to live in dianella
yeah I promise not to come in your mouth
and I promise that the checks in the
mail there you go
I don't want to die in LA I
no I will be right back to Philadelphia
I'll die in Vegas yeah I don't give a
[ __ ] get me out of here by the mountain
in Colorado I don't want to die in LA
and they put you up there next to
Michael Jackson hey people break in
there at night jerk off on your gravy
[ __ ] they think they jerk it off on
Michael Jackson next thing I'm getting
droplets of my eyebrows there are the
caskets oh so that means they gotta make
like a what kind of casket they're gonna
put me in what are you doing a casket I
want to get eaten by worms fire I want
them to find 11 worms with different DNA
from drugs they found these worms that
had was you know how [ __ ] funny that
would be they're all just hi they just
stopped there on their backs just
chilling out I'm shooting me on the fly
report fly report I found my THC flag he
was living alive in the closet
this fly I [ __ ] did like science with
this fly based on a jar I took this
[ __ ] jaw
oh no I took this job little holes in a
weed and I would when the possum died in
this kind this kind of the wall in the
wall we had flies so I would have to all
of them and kill them but a couple of
them I took their wings off and I put
them in this little jar one with one
with the wings on without a way shut up
one I just knocked out a handicap zone
for supplies I put like three or four
flies and this [ __ ] jaw and I would
feed them weed once a week I would take
a little piece of my [ __ ] a little stick
and put it in there let it drop and then
they go crazy and I give my throw team
pile of [ __ ] and [ __ ] them I did lobster
[ __ ] like steak and then one day
something happened the fly got out they
got out and then one night I'm sitting
in my [ __ ] computer about a month ago
and this superb fly lands and he's like
making noises his [ __ ] he's [ __ ] huge
like a satellite and I even hit him any
disappear
and then I found my two days late living
in my jacket like what got a hump you're
like oh yeah this why is it fun he's not
one of your this is one of these mutants
so I lost him polite to around like
marty Feldman he's [ __ ] I do the THC
in my [ __ ] and the protein part of
species of fly he's gonna have Jeff
Goldblum come out of that [ __ ] thank
you create a new [ __ ] fluoride dog oh
my god Joey Diaz fly funny that's great
hate flies I've always hated fly I'm
with you and they lurk when they know
I'm not going like these glass yeah cuz
let me get on the glass and the Sun hits
something some happens to them damn you
got a mind you just [ __ ] with them you
take one wing off then they walk around
wounded without the one ring
[ __ ]
then maybe you think the other wing off
and they really get pissed off that was
a kid I'll put him on toothpicks and
when I'm on fire no this lights gonna
get [ __ ] jacked up like a kangaroo or
some [ __ ] on your weird THC and [ __ ] you
feed them and you're gonna get you get
you that's he's gonna hug you in the
middle with all the bad [ __ ] that's
going on just just start planning your
[ __ ] yeah you're right planning of
them you are you you're [ __ ] trip now
you what the next mission is gonna be
once this thing gets going it's gonna be
slow so this is the time where you start
what you want to do listen if they're
not gonna pay you the [ __ ] suck dick
but you always wanted to be a ballerina
that was the time yeah I'm gonna be a
webcam girl start from zero
oh I was thinking people paid to see my
feet but I got some ugly-ass feet well I
50 year old Irish feet those things come
on man I got size 10 therefore he could
jizz all over them they're like this
thanks for the head
oh yeah
I was a little I was a girl of my niece
one night she's a [ __ ] meds to it
she's very quiet very low-key the
sisters the opposite twenty boyfriends
not just her bikinis this and this this
nice the one that's in med school
she's the hotter one is no we're not
even saying wow we're not even the same
boom so we talking on the horses she
told me she told me okay so what do you
do to make money in med school when she
was farm I'm a tune of this my roommate
she's trying to talk me into some
pictures of my feet people are crazy
with this [ __ ] I didn't even know it was
a thing and her mother was with me my
sister was with us basically and she
goes have you seen me as feet that
beautiful me is like yeah I'm Joey six
and a half guys go crazy oh so like
really I gotta send mine I gotta give my
heart out there right now she's got big
feet no girls got a tremendous ass we
would love her I've been doing so many
squats in my apartment and eating so I
got the Kardashian ass right now you can
make money just don't look at my stomach
squatting with a bikini on shut the [ __ ]
up yeah I started my patreon my patreon
is different though I'm gonna put up
stand up that I never like that I use
Jamie Lee look up a girl named Jamie Lee
and she had comedian host of the hot
mess
she was a P Home Show huh didn't she
write on that peanut home show no way
this girl is [ __ ] funny I know she's
getting paid blow up like the world
trade this [ __ ] but what she
made last week feminism is out the
window with Colvin it died with Corona
listen you gotta if you got a [ __ ] oh
yeah that's the cute girlfriend no no
you got some Jamie Lee go to Twitter
Jamie Lee Virginia Lee that's
comedian maybe it's just Jamie Lee the
chickens in the hope that Mike Jamie Lee
yeah cuz it I don't think Jamie Lee
would stoop to that yet we're almost
there but she's not there yet
maybe the Jamie Lee Fitch does well
Jamie differently you had it on your
phone but you know when I watched
marvelous miss Mazal have you watched
that oh it's it's good but then I got
sucked into a whole Joan Rivers I went
crazy and that's when I started getting
like inspired to do stand-up again and
then when I had a low moment I was like
I'm just gonna sell pictures of my feet
I can't I can't
I'm not technically good so technology
good but I could do my squats for people
if their pay and I didn't know they're
paying for this
this one no that is a different girl I
think they were just private Oh Joey
Joey are you on her fans only page so
[ __ ] funny
you used to sell eggs okay we were
talking about eggs about a month ago
Facebook guys okay she is right there
with the Playboy bunny with the two
fingers oh there you go that makes more
sense
okay Bob oh damn she's got big titty we
spoke on ads and Boston was very sweet
and I was gonna do some Facebook Ads
with her okay all of a sudden the whole
[ __ ] thing it and she Oh tick tock oh
that's not how she would ask somebody
else she put up some stuff and I laughed
my ass off this is her this is her wow
she's tight oh yeah that's all you right
there
click on the picture baby boy look at it
I thought Chico break your back that's
milk chef right there
she's beautiful she's got red hair she's
a funny mom she was she'll do mid three
minutes stand-up topless I'm hoping that
I gave you eight and my titties look
like that he croaks : I'm gonna love
this
oh [ __ ] he go keep going
there's your nutsack and she's from
Boston lay some gay this we go signs he
go she dyed her own hair my girl wait
till you see my girl [ __ ] put that thing
on ly look at that oh yeah look at that
hummus oh yeah look at that Lea are you
[ __ ] nuts and guess what guys I think
my mom was not doing anything upsetting
she's not doing anything x-rated and
she's getting paid and I'm [ __ ] proud
of she's on the one top percent of all
fries I just found out hate rauner fans
only yeah only fans is it somebody was
like you need to start an only fan pain
yeah what happens in quarantine stays in
quarantine I'll fill in you girl we were
back and forth year day I'm not gonna
tell you what she made it's nobody's
business but she's [ __ ] the doing her
thing
get it girl hi I'm mad at her she won't
show her [ __ ] okay she'll do topless
stand up for you with a bikini she'll
dance for you she'll send you pictures
of your feet and that my friend is how
you make a severity so you're saying I'm
[ __ ] I can't make a living you could
make a living every week listen I can
put a wig on put a bikini on and make
more of a living than this girl I'll
shake my ass they will even know don't
just think he's just a fact we gonna
make a nut sack I'll paper okay okay
I'll tape it why you gonna like that
girl no I'll tape them my nutsack in a
way it looks like a [ __ ] and I really
got spread them do you watch tick-tock
seal on that [ __ ] autism teracle no dice
put us on tick-tock write this he put a
video up him and I fighting right and on
the video I'm in the hallway it's in New
York you could see the maid's cart we're
at a hotel he
something online I got mad I'm banging
on his door he comes to the door of
course filming and he's like why cuz he
knew what he did we were arguing on the
phone so he goes Wow what is it and I
was I started yelling at him then I
punched the door and I went to like push
him and they took it off tick-tock
read it put it up as this is the flip
side to me too he women abuse men she
threw him
this is dices girlfriend she threw him
out of we were on tick-tock for an hour
I got written up as an abusive
girlfriend on reddit and they said I was
like well how'd I throw him out I'm in
the hallway you idiots hysterical I
don't know what red it is but they they
said I'm an abuser I don't know what
tick tock is you know right it is a
business tick tocks weird
tick tock it's either a girl doing that
like shaking her ass and then the song
playing over it or kids in the house my
parents are abusive by stepdads abusive
and they film them threatening them and
threatening them to get from I might
call [ __ ] police what are you doing
yeah what see that oh it's awful or
they're crying she said I'm fat I should
kill myself
for the person who said I'm fat maybe
that's why I'm not depressed I watching
all these terrible depressing things I
stopped I had a wean off it it was like
coke you know yeah wean off it it's like
I started a too late with this habit no
get some right now a lot of people at
home don't watch anything you see around
anything you see now like you have to
write it off to somebody who's been home
for two and a half weeks by themselves
their parents are in a nursing home
they're running down on Molly they're
running people are going crazy this
whole crazy [ __ ] on that so I like that
you listen to the podcast I like you
support podcast it's a minimum time that
you should be on the internet right now
I agree
right now this is
listening you've already that's why I
started watching the mains already done
the toughest month of your life okay
you're starting to get used to it get
over yourself
yeah you're starting to get used to it
get the [ __ ] off Netflix you already
exhausted Netflix yeah but at least then
something you can learn or watch a mind
off you know what I don't try to put the
TV is now on my house till five o'clock
I do the same thing no TV till five
that'll kill you that'll put you that's
the quickest way of ending up in a
[ __ ] hole
yeah motional ii physically you gotta do
something yeah am I saying that I want
you to go to the park and walk around in
circles behind somebody else with germs
no but there's something you gotta be
doing I you know what I cleaned half the
office and I gave half that [ __ ] away so
I was a day of my [ __ ] yep I gave away a
robe twenty-two hundred sweatshirts
yeah I'm cleaning that outfit things
that people gave me on the road that
don't fit they were too small to start
off yeah I gave way pounds and that
there's all these shelters opening up
donate to that that's what I said last
the other one the ones across them five
guys across from what we used to have
the office oh and if you go behind there
it's the whatever goodwill this goodwill
so I go I go I'm not big on go well bet
between and that's it that's all you can
do
yeah wait for the deal breathe wait for
whatever information they have and make
a plan I think you're right about make
up the plan is this is the plan I see I
see us opening up if you open up a
football stadium and put 60,000 people
in there we're gonna have another
widespread epidemic isn't there a test
you know that's gonna come back
literally in minutes yes I'm going by
Eddie Griffin or this one but you gotta
take the test and go into the game you
can't go in until you pass right but for
right now I don't even think
go that far okay we just want the games
to happen how can we get the games to
play let's start with the fifth
systematic fest test the Empire's
testing afterward yeah and that's what
determines who plays tomorrow set up
these series just like nobody else the
problem is you can't have people in the
stands from right now especially for
baseball yeah let's start with baseball
by August let's start with 300 people
per game I get it everybody needs to
make money then you have another problem
what are we gonna do with college
football and pro football yeah that's
still low stadium especially college
especially college yeah so right now I
don't know what NC double-a is gonna do
all I could do is this I can't see a
life a year in my life yeah how much
football didn't exist this will be the
first yeah pro football you want to come
back you got a screw the same as you
have to play helmets kill each other
nobody in the [ __ ] audience yeah and
you're still violating rules because you
got 50 guys on his team that's over a
hundred people on the field with the
refs the camera guys the photographer's
the reporters yes you know this is these
all the things that are gonna come from
this you know and then the biggest one
the economics oh yeah come back yeah how
fast are people gonna pay to one in 20
hours to go to see ejected open up
everybody started over I think and those
ticket prices are going down but after
they go down I think everybody has to
make the sacrifice here yeah so I guess
I worry about the airlines I feel like
they're gonna hurt us after they're
really gonna hurt us but what are you
gonna do first off I can't get on a
plane till I know this is vaccine yeah
once the flu is there ever gonna be a
vaccine I don't know but I'm not worried
about the flu I'm worried about but
people get attacks means that I missed
war
have underlying pressure got high blood
pressure and do I really want to go to
Vegas if they're only gonna have 400
seats available for me to see these are
all decisions I'm gonna make I'm not
starting off with 5-hour flights I'm
starting off to more my immune system
again I've been flying for 20 years my
immune system is already to put like
it's strong
yeah it's also weak because of the
amount of marijuana I've smoked and for
years I know the [ __ ] I have what do you
thinks gonna happen in Vegas I'm
supposed to be in Vegas May the first
second first again yeah July you think
they're gonna cancel my may no they may
yes that's Mother's Day it's but that
week they haven't cancelled yet you're
you're closed till May 15 so whatever
you had some late 14th is done but they
couldn't open if they wanted so unless
they open up to follow a weekend how
many people gonna be mentally physically
psychologically and economically
prepared yeah [ __ ] there you find all a
two-drink minimum
play so now will coming in for the
summer months anybody who's done calmly
on an early stage and level knows that
when they call the Booker the Booker
always says to you Lisa at Cheryl
[ __ ] high you're not too easy but by
the way you do know what summer pack
this [ __ ] don't pay in the winter yeah
so that's what I'm saying I don't make
that much money top of California I'm
the summer pay if you're the top of
California mm-hmm you have states like
Minneapolis Buffalo Seattle Portland
there's a handful of states if anybody
remembers please tweet me that you can
get Minneapolis Minneapolis
Milwaukee okay there's a handful of
states that business drop so is Julie oh
yeah they go so many things on the
weekends and they do so many things
together outside hey go what ya already
in numbers go away Buffalo New York
yeah if Jesus is playing the drums in
the building you ain't getting people in
there July 31st he's got to be outdoor
they want to be outdoor Buffalo's been
in the outfit nine months they've been
out for nine months they stepped out to
smoke cigarettes to get away from
Grandma
while she's wheezing you know he's now
North Dakota South Dakota these are all
theta in the summer people run Seattle
people run you know so we're going into
that for recovery yeah that's our
economic recovery so now we're waiting
on people getting checks we're waiting
on this well let me ask you this boom
and I know cuz normally comedy outside
isn't great what do you think that Mike
get a little bit more populist here so
you can like stand outside yeah gonna
have a [ __ ] a numbers about whether
it's inside or outside they're still
gonna be the same amount of numbers that
you could have under that tent okay now
number two let's switch this let's
switch this Eleanor I [ __ ] love you I
don't know if you know this I've had a
crush on you for 30 years and I've got
three [ __ ] two VIP tickets to take
you to go see Dave Chappelle in Atlanta
yeah August 12th outdoor at the outdoor
thought okay you know look at me and say
okay okay and then you're gonna be
walking to work one day and you're gonna
see me and Lee walking down the street
with to sweat puddles underarms and the
humidity a Friday before that's showing
hmm so this new hot light joy wants to
take me on a date to Atlanta
what if I end up sitting next to those
two fat [ __ ] ah that's what under their
arms in humans bill in Georgia which is
getting hit hard with the corona yeah so
we have now you have to tell me what you
think what are you gonna do are you
really gonna run to the Dodger game are
you really gonna run to that
Philadelphia and now we got football oh
the Eagle ball I love I can't see a
world without football yeah the same way
I can't see a world without basketball
or baseball football I love there's a
little bit bigger the audience more
people sell and sweat sure you take you
take the Eagles fans if you take that
away from them you thought they were
angry before 400 this is what's gonna
happen let me set and everybody else do
I open it to capacity these cities are
gonna inciting it going into the
holidays hey so it's tough as it is what
do you think every man now is telling
you there's gonna be the toughest week
we've endured that you said two weeks
ago yeah this is just every state and as
long as every state is going through it
and they're gonna start to mandate it
and go state-by-state to see what's
really going on with numbers all but if
you fly listen if you fly into Dallas
right now what if you gotta fly into
Dallas all you're safe to do three shows
with Andrew
you gotta get there July 16 because you
got a quarantine for two weeks yeah
that's that's the problem with the
flying so right now nobody knows nothing
so what your element was gonna do is
know is he's gonna hunker down it's so
pictures of my face you have to she
might have to cancel Hulu she might have
to cancel her water yeah thank God the
gym is closing so you that saves you 89
a month you know things are also gonna
close and go away yeah what you gonna
save you a little bit
and then you're gonna do spots at the
story and do your podcast again you're
gonna jump on shows and when you're
ready psychologically then you get back
on your plate so do whatever go back to
the lifestyle you were living yeah it
takes a minute it just it the first we
stopped doing the comedy star podcast
because Rick had to have a surgery then
his daughter got sick it's a scary time
like and then I was like alright I'll
figure out the technical part of it and
then you just take care of your family
you know cuz I don't have kids or
anything so and then my computer I got
like a weird virus and I was like oh
everybody has a virus that's the whole
thing
so I just freaked out I was like I can't
even buy a new computer you know to me I
mean I guess I can order it online but I
can't I'd have to have somebody come set
it I got to start slightly so I can get
it to go right you know in a man like
it's not our we love to do that oh yes
okay all the sudden II don't know if
they'll fear
it's got no problem sleeping with me to
fix my computer everybody's got a price
I mean a gmask and this always you
remember one thing as a comic cuz uh but
I do miss doing the podcast is what I'm
saying I miss I couldn't imagine not
doing this twice a week yeah this has to
be done twice a week for me and for them
ya know is so much fun yeah I know they
know exactly this is great to get out
but whose dad doing with my daughter I
love that I come here and do the science
one with that little Turkey and last
week though was a television so we
covered the gold mines a television how
it became yeah bustling to cable in that
way
DirecTV is pretty interesting know last
week was the piano I'm sorry
oh she's one electric piano and played
songs okay
does the school Center a computer
it's got a program that you could play
so I told you the keys
nice so she's over and I'm over here
[ __ ] singing whatever that's great
[Music]
every song she sings got it hey at the
Madlib she loses a body
dad it's not there and then I'll show it
the honey it says yay right there but
they took it out just in Spanish I just
told men how do you are you teaching her
Spanish yes good good I talked to a lot
in Spanish she's not going to talk back
to me
yeah it's absorbing yeah yeah they asked
her a question in Spanish and she said
yes so ah I know that she's getting it
I'm learning it but only by watching one
art goes it's gonna come to her what
seasons are you really well done yeah
one of the best series I've ever seen I
finished the last one already what do
you think of this this last series I
thought it was great
did you like the beach huh did you like
it more than the first season I love the
Pablo you mean that way or narcos Mexico
20 okay
the first season was of narcos Mexico
was excellent excellent excellent I
loved every character but this the women
more this season I love like hardcore
[ __ ] just stepping up to the plate
feels right a big tender one yeah why
she's single she has like a [ __ ] bull
mastiff so I'm watching this with my
pants at half-mast for both people the
women and the men the other night have
watched but I gotta read the whole thing
you know you have to pee
and the sad thing is that I've read what
they say havoc is completely different
well okay they have to translate it
that's what I might do Lee what's that
that's my idea
well your idea comes in thank you very
much what oh come on it would well
twitch not
and tell people what they're really
saying the only problem is Oh talk to
somebody because I wanted to do
something like that it's just a
copyright whoa Tony you mean when they
put it in English Simone said that not a
Netflix is adding a feature you can type
you can type with lately they just can't
hear him what do you mean I thought we
could have like a narcos party we can't
just do it they can take it down like
that real spec telling you what he
really said Oh instead of what cuz
that's what that when he bought him that
tiger oh please oh sorry oh okay what
about episode 1 of that [ __ ] yeah
episode even Kali so this week I watched
a couple episodes of Kali but I watched
the one that the end when he when the
two gay guys came and hit him in the
head with a bottle then he ripped him
apart with a motorcycle
first of all I had the biggest crush on
him and I was like I just he's gay
listen yeah I go crazy from I watch the
[ __ ] first four episodes of narcos
and last night I watched the one cuz
episode three with Pablo is after he
thousand he wants to be candidate Oh
then his wife goes home he goes home
she's puking mm-hmm she said I don't
want you close to him again
yeah he's like don't worry this is just
business I don't want nothing to do it
on and they show him him flopping it
[ __ ] the chicken the [ __ ] and she's
like it's just the way you [ __ ] your
wife standing up and he [ __ ] grabs
about a [ __ ] throughout [ __ ] kill
you she's like you understand dirty
[ __ ] it's so hard puts it down I hope
you do it like that Lee I hope it
doesn't have the balls to wear the
gloves to grab you might have thrown it
the [ __ ] got it he grabs her by the ahh
and then he lets it down and she goes
hey sorry Pablo is there something I can
do for you
why bother she goes how about you [ __ ]
me in the ass
and she turns over he just just you know
haha
so now episode 4 opens up with Pablo
when she's tied up you know remember
yeah she opens up tying up in lingerie
look I'm gonna re-watch it all quickly I
hit a [ __ ] roofie like Kate took a hit
a roofie the guy told don't worry I'm
gonna get you a job just have this drink
and then she's okay ain't you with
[ __ ] she's waking up on all five
fours and he's got a gun in the
newspaper throws the newspaper her
things like this is what you're telling
people she's got a [ __ ] mask on and
[ __ ] and she continued to [ __ ] him out
oh yeah that was the game they play yeah
I guess so hot put the gun Tyrone color
just what you want and then you can see
him just take the gun and pull all the
way down at between her legs and he puts
it between her [ __ ] and he actually
starts [ __ ] RAM and a little bit it's
tremendous [ __ ] it's so good - man
that's episode five before the a
brand-new show nobody takes chances like
that I feel bad because and I'll say it
for you America I even like this tried
to watch nycos but the [ __ ] subtitles
are brutal I love it and you're not
nothing I'm not even a fast reader I'm
at the movement oh me too me too
[ __ ] like man I like Marco's
but the Mexicans talk way fast [ __ ] I
get it it's tough so maybe I'll do
something where you say press play now
even the Burt Reynolds DEA guy he looks
like a hot Burt Reynolds the American
well he didn't season yeah not the white
the gringo but he's Spanish but he works
with America the gringos the first guy
that
bachchi Fox yeah yeah yeah yeah um that
day that's a different articles if
that's what you're always we remember
there's somebody's room will say you
know great and Marcos and me I'm gonna
go into the guy Liberace they got [ __ ]
me won't you leave me alone what are you
gonna do this I can't wait I want to be
part of it or watch it this you
narrating I think pick me up with twitch
and I go on there one night wait four
episodes you got a smoke a joint before
you do every episo-- something just a
[ __ ] around yeah
who listen how long do we have really no
yeah with me
I am very insecure I get all fired up I
go [ __ ] it let me go online and do a
periscope and I go yeah you know why cuz
late o'clock I see people playing
violins on there do people playing drums
on there I see so many people trying
their arse out there I'm like how am I
gonna go out there smoke a joint and
call the people [ __ ] well there's
people with actually that artists so
they're really trying to do [ __ ] for the
community how about that breaking that
balls I'm not doing it that's the reason
why I don't do it because I feel bad
every day that's not it's secure that
you being like sense I see these people
I get insecure why I don't finish
setting something up I'm like I did two
videos for YouTube and I still don't put
them up I see these people you know they
don't give the audience a break I'm a
break it's always a question they send
you this they do this the best of these
celebrities I'm gonna tase some
celebrities are really full and bad if
the New York Times are nautical the
other night yeah what reason not gonna
fare well from this you know these guys
are do that first off after these
[ __ ] on steroids I love the
ones that are on steroids and tell you
they're at the gym at six lifting
weights you make 80 million dollars a
half a year you've got 82 people working
for you yeah you know that's my favorite
god shoot happy
American public the fan base of all
these suppers because that's what they
are I love these guys that walk around
all I eat a clean diet and meantime they
go up to I know exactly where they go
the guy shoots him twice a week they
going through the back door or they got
enough money the guy just comes to their
house yeah and he poses as a
chiropractor and they go in the back
he's gonna stretch me out and nobody
knows nothing that gives you too many
shots you give him a check from a
different account and nobody knows
nothing and these are the guys I see the
most doing all the exercises and guys
get over it and then I see the remark
from people in America like all thank
you
you know setup you working with a
[ __ ] cheetah yeah these people all
cheat they all want you and you know
what they're non-essential these doctors
do whatever so they're gonna go away and
in a couple months you're gonna see what
these people really are what they really
look like how they really because
there's no more cheating you can't cheat
now these doctors are gonna go out of
business you don't think it's gonna be
an interesting new world yeah sorry time
to shine the real me I'm excited about
is getting on that stage I got a 90-day
trial
I got a 90 day to get my dirty oh you're
giving yourself ninety-eight I got it
you're treating it like insurance
nothing matters that comes out of my
mouth I got a date September 5th and 6th
in Utah
I'll Drive I got so many dates
I got San Diego August 1st I got Vegas
July 31st
that's all that's officially in the
books right now
Wow Brea Jul 14 the sixth it's four
shows how many people can I possibly put
net first off I don't know if I'm doing
any improv nightclubs I'm removing the
first three rows really I spit when I
talk I've been spit when I talk along
with the face
years people told me you may have news
not the weather for years since I was a
kid people told me that when you're on
stage no matter what you get excited I'm
removing the first three rows of every
cobweb what if we just put the big glass
like the supermarket's do that's the
Blues Brothers we still have to have
some energy flow with the [ __ ]
audience
it'd just be a whole little windshield
wiper Danny I don't want to do anything
to freak the audience out any more than
they are I want them to come to this
experience relaxed and I'm gonna put
that in my ride is everything okay
you're gonna have to get your own
microphone I want my own I don't want my
audience to sit there like understand am
I gonna now we have two different things
am I gonna get shot Oh am I gonna get
coal pit there's an [ __ ] come in here
and say jihad kills and shoots me with a
[ __ ] water pistol or [ __ ] Swami
from salami coffin behind me telling
people it's his allergies gonna give me
Kovac we have so many things now that I
have to compete with yeah this is kind
of a weird thing to ask but I was
thinking about if I wanted to write
jokes about what's going on I was like
no people don't want to hear that but I
was also thinking like it's gonna be
seated this is genuine to just go up
there doing the jokes I was doing before
this your world yeah it's your point of
view
folks all jokes are gone
it's a new you you just been you did
just took away part of how the way you
live are you gonna go through no joy
this was thinking that wasn't all state
of mind
yeah these jokes are coming from the new
state of mind is their [ __ ] COBIT
gonna be mentioned yeah it's gonna be is
there gonna be hacked
jokes about it yeah of course your spin
on it when I was in blah blah blah you
know I almost gonna go up there and say
you know what I don't give a [ __ ]
whatever you [ __ ] said I mean it
really scared me
yeah and you're gonna go up there with
your physicality is same old Victor the
semi-date I was yeah I was walking into
McDonald beethoven's busted look at me
I'm still alive it pays to be a chubby
guy was a bunk you guys for not paying
for my feet well that's what I'm gonna
say okay everybody has a different thing
whatever you want to do is boil you have
a plan for what's coming it'll make
what's going on why now less sickening
less secondly you know I'm saying like
everybody has a plan you have one if you
don't have a plan you better sit down
like Pontius Pilate
right now Pontius Pilate is what Jesus
what the check and he busted out of the
grace lockup send the Puerto Rican
brothers send the McNeeley send
everybody Jesus I'm a loose and right
now you like calling a BP you got lights
going up you got ring this [ __ ]
busted out of a cave and left a noose
and left like a note my father's coming
I'm coming for everybody come down here
and straighten out everybody listen I'm
happy you took the time thank you so
much for having me
I hope the church family really
appreciate I love the church and they
remember that you till you came out in
this I got come on this time we already
now I go home I jump in the [ __ ]
shower I wash and we mind and we eat and
take like a Silkwood scrub down yep I'm
watching the worst kids TV oh yeah
listen whatever problems I had like I
thought if Jesus would have put me in
purgatory
I earn my stripes the last days I've
been watching such bad cartoons these
kids don't even buy Popeye Popeye the
rocks you almost had a heart attack
really why don't you so skinny why is he
beating up the big guy they can't people
will [ __ ] up who was chasing the rod
will try to blow a mob was gladly pay
you Tuesday today
these kids they got half of iTunes they
break into dance and for the beginning
everybody's eating you know yeah you're
really gonna hang out with a Hindu kid
three white kids they're really gonna
have a Hindu kid who's over there eating
eggs in the corner it's a realistic
business I love you [ __ ] and I
love you for always supporting us and
having our back Monday Wednesday
Thursday Tuesday
just like Apollonia before she got blown
up
oh my you guys don't give up [ __ ] jack
let me see what I got here cuz my
[ __ ] glasses got all fogged up with
this fossil yeah yeah yeah these masts
they just fog up your glasses I'm trying
to figure out what I can write on the
mast I could sell them for a dollar
apiece
like so oh yeah let's stay away sucker
so I'll keep you libido away to church
you know something this or something I
could send these [ __ ] boom
that's the wrong one this is what you're
looking for
yeah oh I meant the world to me when you
said cuz I would add um you would zoom I
would assume you then kept it on and I
will resume deep into you [ __ ] when
you didn't figure I will figure out zoom
to get you on the collar [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
listen everybody's avoiding crowds right
now but if you need to get to the post
office you might be running a small
business trying to ship product or
sending invoices I can't blame you but I
need to do with the post office you
could do with stamps calm and I got big
news
stamps.com is not working on UPS
get more delivery options and all the
great discounts
posted that you use to stamps calm and
UPS my wife's been using stamps comp
forever if you want me to sit here and
tell you some [ __ ] story it's not
gonna happen it's the real deal it's
easier it saves your time and it saves
your money and the story
stamps.com brings the post office to you
it's like Sophia Loren you know I'm
saying skip the line print the postage
24/7 any letter any sized package going
anywhere in the world right from your
couch and the best part is the mailman
will come and pick it up dah dah dah dah
there's no contract required it's simple
you also get that great discounts get
five cents off every first-class stamp
and up to 40% off shipping who's better
than uncle Joey nobody and you save 62%
on ups rent rates plus you never pay
residual residential surcharges again
guys stamp tom is a no-brainer
especially now I'm saving your time
money and I'm also keeping you safe so
right now they got a special offer you
ready grab a pen I'm gonna give you a
four week trial offer free plus free
postage and a digital scale no long term
combat contracts no long term
commitments it's easy go to Stan stop
calm clicking the microphone at the top
of the homepage and pressed church that
stamps.com
and press in church I told you my wife
bit some been with Stan's since we've
been shipping t-shirts sweatshirts
anything from Joey Diaz Nets get shipped
on stamps comm do me a favor go to
Stan's comm press in church but most
importantly stay safe my friends I want
to thank I don't know Martinez but yeah
this [ __ ] I want to thank the
flying Jew
being here but most importantly I want
to thank you guys from the bottom of my
heart without you guys we'd have nothing
I hope that these podcasts i helping you
doing this tough time we're just in here
talking [ __ ] true because that's what
it's all about just taking your mind off
of what's going on and keep it off go
get a notebook don't start your own
podcast gonna make candles go learn how
to make biscuits go do something you
know I'm saying it's better than sitting
there feeling sorry for yourself waiting
for the Bluebird of happiness that
[ __ ] hasn't showed in years okay
he ain't gonna show up you gotta assume
he ain't gonna show up they want to be
happy gonna get yourself there on your
own
I got anxiety out the ass I'm over there
hitting the bag I can feel the [ __ ]
stroke blowing up my neck Shh but let's
keep punching you know why because we're
gonna be fine and we'll get this we're
gonna get through this together like the
church family will always do sending
love out to Bob love linga sending love
out the hub's to Scott Cunningham Chad
Reed all you [ __ ] I know you
are I've been watching you and Michael
Kern whatever your [ __ ] name is kind
of sucker turn Michael I know no Michael
you're good people you're all good
people thank you for keep writing stuff
on the pages a lot of babies being born
I keep saying congratulations to a lot
of you guys so I know you're doing the
right thing thank you very much for
listening thank you very much for being
part of the church and [ __ ] them all oh
you did go to church today there you go
they can all suck your dick
take this [ __ ] meal Lee
[Applause]
[Music]